most common mistake entrepreneurs who
have small businesses make they believe
that they should know how to do
everything better than everyone on their
team and in the beginning that is true
oftentimes it's not necessarily correct
but it's often true they bring people in
who don't know something they teach them
everything they have and then they say
oh I need to find another person I have
to bring them in and teach them
everything I have but what happens is a
business is always the accumulation of
all the knowledge of everyone in the
business but if everyone learned
everything from you then it means only
one brain is responsible for all the
growth and at some point that brain is
going to cap out just depends where and
then at the point that you realize that
you have to find people who are better
than you at certain things who know
things that you don't know is the point
where you'll be able to unlock the
leverage of growth of other smart people
and that's where recruiting to build the
infrastructure transitions from one guy
with a genius and a thousand hands to a
true Enterprise